video nummer 157 szene viertakter rein
einige von euch haben mich vermutlich
vor diesem regal hier kennengelernt denn
angefangen hat doktor watson mal wie bei
so ziemlich jedem youtuber im wohnzimmer
klar damals war ich auch noch komplett
alleine also habe ich ganz schlicht
meine wohnung zum filmset
umfunktionieren
ziemlich genau drei jahre und knapp
80.000 abonnenten später kam dann aber
der nächste große schritt aus doktor
watson oder eine gmbh aus der ein mann
band ein team oder aus meinem alten
wohnzimmer hier unser studio dass ihr
wahrscheinlich alle kennt und der
zentrale baustein davon ist der blaue
hintergrund hinter mir auf dem wir je
nach thema passende muster oder auch
illustrationen einfügen können und die
sorgen dafür dass die videos so aussehen
wie sie nun mal aussehen aber ob ihr es
glaubt oder nicht dieser hintergrund ist
tatsächlich kein greenscreen auch wenn
das noch bis heute viele von euch laufen
diese wand hier existiert tatsächlich
genauso wie die dinge die hier rumstehen
und diese lampe hier nichts davon ist
digital heute erklären euch endlich wie
wir das geschafft haben aber auch warum
green screens so häufig so schlecht
aussehen und durch was sie gerade von
hollywood ersetzt werden
[Musik]
dies sei
green screens sind überall längst werden
sie nicht mehr nur für film und
fernsehen genutzt sondern auch für tritt
streams und sogar zoom calls überall wo
man menschen und dinge in eine andere
welt transportieren möchte kommt der
green screen zum einsatz wenn er gut
gemacht ist ist der komplett unsichtbar
manchmal fällt er aber auch extrem auf
und zerstört die illusion
das prinzip ist eigentlich recht simpel
unser ziel ist es dem hintergrund hinter
einer person durch etwas anderes zu
ersetzen
dafür müssen wir die person vom
hintergrund trennen also sozusagen
ausschneiden
das kann man auf verschiedene art und
weisen machen unter anderem indem man
wortwörtlich um die person herum
schneidet und zwar bild für bild dieser
prozess nennt sich fotos kopie und das
gerade für längere film schnipsel extrem
mühselig 24 bilder pro sekunde sind bei
einigen minuten filmmaterial eine menge
bilder
deswegen kam ein cleverer filmemacher
namens lorenz butler 1940 auf eine idee
was wenn man die person nicht für
irgendein im hintergrund filmt sondern
vor einer einfarbigen wand so kann man
diese spezifische farbe quasi heraus
löschen und übrig bleibt alles andere
nämlich unsere person im vordergrund
das war die geburtsstunde des kroatien
für die butler 1941 einen visual effects
oscar gewann
damals hat man das allerdings noch ein
bisschen anders gemacht zum einen war
der heute typische greenscreen damals
noch einen bluescreen bluescreens werden
zwar auch heute noch verwendet aber
seltener
das liegt daran dass digitale kameras im
grünen bereich die höchste auflösung
haben und auch daran dass grünen am
weitesten von typischen hautfarben
entfernt ist der zweite große
unterschied war damals arbeitete man
natürlich noch mit richtigem cellulite
film was den ganzen prozess des kings
und vor allem das compositing es also
das zusammenfügen es mit einem neuen
hintergrund deutlich komplizierter macht
das was man damals noch mit chemischen
prozessen und projektoren lösen musste
geht heute im digitalen zeitalter mit
software und wenigen klicks man wählt
einfach die genaue farbe des green
screens aus und schon radiert mir die
software den hintergrund komplett weg da
alle technik aber wo ist denn da der
haken wenn der prozess so einfach und
zugänglich ist warum sie ihn dann so
viele green screen szenen immer noch so
fade und einfach schlecht aus das kann
uns marian erklären denn machen es bei
uns kameramann chef der postproduktion
und ist für die entwicklung des
visuellen konzepts von doktor watson
mitverantwortlich gewesen und er ist es
auch heute noch und fun fact er ist auch
derjenige der das video hier gerade
schneidet es gibt eigentlich drei
hauptprobleme warum green screens sehr
schwierig gut umzusetzen sind das erste
ist die interaktion mit der umwelt
dadurch dass wir das subjekt
ausschneiden und irgendwo einsetzen wo
es eigentlich nicht wahr haben wir
natürlich diese ganze interaktion licht
schatten aber auch zum beispiel haare
oder kleidung die wind wehen
die bewegung der kamera im
dreidimensionalen raum das sind alles
sachen die entweder komplett fehlen oder
wir müssen es halt mit viel aufwand und
planungen simulieren und selbst dann
passt es manchmal nicht zu 100% unser
gehirn ist einfach viel zu gut da drin
die realität sozusagen zu unterscheiden
von der simulation und kann deswegen aus
dieser illusion dadurch rausgerissen
werden
das zweite problem ist dann das
ausschneiden selbst dass man das
wirklich sauber hinbekommt denn wenn wir
dem computer letztendlich einfach nur
sagen alle grünen pixel macht die
transparent löscht die raus und alle
anderen behältst du musst der computer
natürlich in diesen semitransparenten
bereichen entscheiden wurden bisschen
grün mit drin steckt ob das jetzt noch
gerade zum hintergrund gehört oder
chance im vordergrund und da gibt es
natürlich viele slider und
einstellungsmöglichkeiten die einem
dabei helfen das fein zu tun aber häufig
gehen dabei trotzdem ganz ganz feine
details verloren und man muss erstens
super viel zeit reinstecken und zweitens
funktioniert eigentlich auch nur dann
überzeugend wenn man schon einen
perfekten bedingungen gedreht hat das
ganze das dritte problem entsteht eben
auch wenn man ihn nicht perfekten
bedingungen dreht also wenn
beispielsweise der green scan to hell
ausgeleuchtet ist oder der abstand zu
dann reflektiert der green screen ja
immer auch ein teil des lichts und der
farbe vor allem zurück und dann haben
wir etwas was wir spinnen spiel heißt
überlaufen wenn man es übersetzt in dem
fall besteht das überlaufen in einem
grünen schleier der in bereichen landet
wo man ihn eigentlich nicht haben will
in den hautfarben zum beispiel das sieht
einerseits sehr kränklich aus und
andererseits haben wir dann auch wieder
dieses problem dass der computer pixel
als green screen interpretiert die
eigentlich keinen greenscreen sind all
das sind probleme die dafür sorgen dass
gerade in amateur produktionen green
screens häufig sehr sehr schlecht
aussehen aber es ist tatsächlich sogar
so fun fact dass selbst bei krassen
hollywoodproduktionen wie zb ventures
oder sowas szenen die eigentlich sogar
vor green screen gedreht wurden am ende
doch händisch ausgeschnitten werden
einfach weil es besser aussieht und man
mehr kontrolle darüber hat
ok also alles gar nicht so einfach wie
es erst mal auf dem papier klingt aber
wie löst man denn jetzt diese probleme
wir haben wir es geschafft keinen spiel
und kann die kanten probleme zu bekommen
und dass man trotzdem noch jedes haar
von mir erkennen kann
nun ich sparen euch noch eine minute auf
die folter denn es gibt ein paar geniale
methoden green screens zu ersetzen die
wir nicht verwendet haben aber über die
ich trotzdem gerne sprechen möchte zum
beispiel kann man dem computer
beibringen das subjekt auf eine andere
art und weise zu erkennen
eine inzwischen relativ bekannte technik
basiert auf gesichts beziehungsweise
objekterkennung hier werden algorithmen
benutzt die nicht einfach irgendwelche
farbwerte zum ausschneiden verwenden
sondern tatsächlich versuchen zu
verstehen was das objekt ist dass sie
ausschneiden sollen manchmal wird hier
sogar machine learning eingesetzt also
künstliche intelligenz wenn man so will
die meisten von euch kennen das
wahrscheinlich von videokonferenzen fast
jedes programm das man heutzutage dafür
nutzt besitzt irgendeine möglichkeit den
hintergrund durch einen anderen zu
ersetzen oder unscharf zu machen
auch die künstliche tiefenschärfe in der
smartphone kamera wird oft auf diese art
und weise generiert all diese
technologien werden mit den jahren immer
besser und ich finde es mir ja krass ist
wie so was inzwischen einfach so mit uns
in der hosentasche herum tragen können
bis wir hier bei kinoqualität sind wird
es trotzdem noch ein bisschen dauern
eine für uns filmschaffende besonders
spannend technik geht deswegen quasi in
die andere richtung und verzichtet
komplett auf software tricks
und zwar indem sie den green screen
tatsächlich durch einen screen also
einen bildschirm ersetzt
hier haben wir beides miteinander
vereint eine digitale projektionsfläche
auf der virtuelle umgebungen dargestellt
werden können und gleichzeitig eine
fotorealistische interaktion zwischen
umgebung und der person darin indirekte
beleuchtung reflektionen und sogar so
etwas kompliziertes wie ihre fraktionen
funktionieren alle genauso wie man das
an einem physischen set erwarten würde
besonders bekannt wurde die technik
durch die serie dem ende lorien nicht
nur dass wir hier keine der typischen
probleme von green screens haben
die kamera ist außerdem in echtzeit mit
der engine verbunden die diese 3d
umgebungen generiert so wird bei
bewegung der kamera eine 100%
realistische tiefenwahrnehmung simuliert
was schutz ermöglicht die
herkömmlicherweise viele viele stunden
in der post produktion gekostet hätten
this is the way aber was ist denn jetzt
das prinzip bei uns hier im studio
naja die virtuellen leds ages von dem
ende lori und konnten wir uns leider
gerade so nicht leisten auch haben wir
keine armada von praktikanten im keller
die mich alle bild für bild fotos
kopieren
aber wir haben eine andere methode
gefunden die uns von den grundzügen her
tatsächlich wieder zurück zum anfang
dem traum akin bringt diese ganzen
probleme die wir gerade eben
angesprochen haben bestehen ja
eigentlich nur deswegen bei unser ziel
ist die pixel vom green screen am ende
komplett zu löschen und durch was
anderes zu ersetzen und deswegen war
unsere idee wir umgehen und das ganze
einfach indem wir beide pixel behalten
also quasi den screen selber und das was
wir darauf anwenden
aber was heißt das jetzt konkret heißt
das wir drehen sich halt vor dieser wand
die bewusst in einem blau grau ton
gestrichen ist den können wir dann halt
ansprechen als wäre es ein bluescreen
aber anstatt dann die pixel zu löschen
behalten wir sie und haben sich quasi
als zusätzliche maske ausgeschnitten die
wir dann einfach darüber legen können
das heißt wir haben die band selber als
unterste ebene
dann haben wir eine ebene mit den
illustrationen die wir gerne einfügung
wollen und dich dann noch mal als
ausgeschnittener cedric oben drüber und
der große vorteil ist jetzt selbst wenn
wir keinen perfekten key hinbekommen was
je nach dem was du auch an hass oder so
durchaus auch vorkommt
und irgendwelche details verlieren dann
ist das nicht so schlimm weil ein
verlorenes h auf der einen ebene immer
noch auf der untersten ebene quasi als
backup liegt und das fällt dann halt nur
auf wenn wir jetzt animation haben die
genau zwischen dieses detail und dem
hintergrund fällt und so wie wir die
animation eben gestalten ist das in der
regel nicht der fall und auch das bild
ist ja komplett realistisch weil die
digitale umgebung zu 99 prozent die
tatsächliche umgebung beim dreh war wenn
du sofort anschließen würde man ja ein
blaues bilder warten der darf da drin
sein im gegensatz zu einem natürlichen
green screens bild okay da habt ihr es
das ist also das geheimnis hinter der
doktor watson band es ist kein
greenscreen es ist quasi ein bluescreen
den wir in sap integriert haben ich
hoffe euch hat dieser kleine blick
hinter die kulissen gefallen ich weiß
dass es heute kein typisches doktor
watson thema war
aber es gab wie gesagt viele unter euch
die diese funktionsweise unseres studios
interessiert hat und wir bieten ja alle
filmemacher innen und reden deswegen
sowieso immer sehr sehr gerne über
solche dinge an dieser stelle auch noch
mal danke an alle die an der entwicklung
dieses hintergrunds beteiligt waren
insbesondere an meinen kollegen und
ehemaligen filmschule kommilitonen mit
der die ursprüngliche idee für das
prinzip hier hatte
wenn ihr mehr solcher videos hier über
film und fernsehen sehen wollt dann
schreibt uns das gerne mal in die
kommentare wir machen wie gesagt sehr
gerne videos darüber zum beispiel haben
wir auch schon länger überlegt mal ein
video zu machen indem wir im detail die
entstehung eines doktor watson videos
dokumentieren was sie von der ersten
idee bis zum upload wenn das video
online geht
wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollte dann
abonniert den kanal und ansonsten immer
bleibt neugierig
[Musik]